il était son éditorialiste à valeurs
actuelles critique dramatique au figaro
magazine directeur de l'avant scène
théâtre chroniqueur culturel dans
diverses émissions
jean françois kahn co fondateur de
marianne président du conseil
d'administration de marianne et ça voilà
alors vous pensez quoi de ce cp philippe
vous pensez que c'est un un contrat de
travail unique est unique en europe ou
un mal nécessaire compte tenu de la
situation de l'emploi des jeunes
moi j'étais pour le cpe ouais moi je
suis j'étais et je suis encore pour tout
ce qui peut déverrouiller les obstacles
qui se dressent contre l'emploi
n'importe quoi
tout pourvu que les jeunes trouvent dans
les meilleures conditions le plus beau
dans les plus mauvaises conditions mais
le plus vite possible un emploi cela dit
la sphère était très bas la manche est
très mal géré je trouve que villepin a
été très maladroit au point que je on
peut se demander s'il ne l'a pas fait
exprès c'est à dire s'ils ne veut pas
provoquer dans le pays
une épreuve de force faire péter les
choses parce qu'il faudra bien que les
choses prennent un jour c'est sûr
la france pourra pas rester à la
situation dans laquelle elle est
éternellement je vois déjà jean-françois
ricaner mais ça n'est pas possible la
france ne pourra pas vivre longtemps
encore la façon dont elle vit il faudra
que la crise un jour éclater un
seulement quand on veut faire éclater la
crise comme l'avait fait margaret
thatcher en son temps en angleterre les
préparer il faut préparer le terrain il
faut préparer l'opinion
il faut avoir une assise non seulement
une assise parlementaire mais une assise
psychologique une assise populaire
meilleur des cas ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui en france voilà longtemps
que si il est allé trop loin et je
regrette que chirac et épousé son point
de vue car je crois que le risque que
prend le gouvernement dans cette affaire
c'est à dire le risque d'une crise est
née sera néfaste à l'intérêt général et
peut-être même néfaste à l'intérêt de
tous les acteurs du drame
aussi bien les syndicats qui ne doivent
pas croire qu'ils s'en tireront un thème
du conflit qui risquent de surgir
et la jeunesse et surtout la jeunesse
dont il est vrai que l'enjeu essentiel
de toute cette affaire c'est quand même
la jeunesse son équilibre son avenir or
la jeunesse c'est quand même c'est très
respectable mais c'est très
incontrôlable et est aujourd'hui tout le
monde est à la traîne de la jeunesse et
c'est ça oui c'est là où il a gravité de
la crise mais c'est pour ou contre vous
au départ non comme patron je suis
vachement pour attend prendre un employé
pouvoir le prendre et le virer quand on
veut ce formidable marque et ne pas le
payer du tout c'est encore mieux pour un
patron j'aimerais beaucoup mais comme
citoyen je trouve que c'est très
difficile c'est inacceptable pour un
jeune ça mais vous savez moi je vais
vous dire et quand quand on étudie jeu
le l'histoire de france c'est très
intéressant parce qu on remarque une
chose c'est que toute l'histoire de
france est ponctuée toujours par un
événement si à un moment il ya une
régression de trop series
on a l'impression qu'ils se passe rien
quoique tout éternelle et puis il ya une
régression toujours par exemple je
prends un seul exemple quand vous avez
le règne de louis-philippe sa durée 18
ans à 18 ans et un regain peu comme ça
conservateur et c'est vrai que pour moi
il se passait rien c'était d'un calme
absolument limpide l'impression que
c'était éternelle ça n'est jamais changé
bon on est revenus sur toutes les
promesses qu'on avait faite au début sur
les acquis mais bon ya un espèce de
fatalisme c'est comme ça on peut rien
faire ça bougera pas etc
et puis un jour vous avez des gens qui
ont dit que tant d il ya 350 mille
personnes seulement qu'en droit de voter
mais qui sont très riches
c'est quand même pas beaucoup si on
portait sa 450 milles s'est pas séparé
extremis
aujourd'hui non pas question et c'est
alors ils disent on va protester mais à
l'époque on pouvait pas faire de meeting
on pouvait pas manifester dans la rue on
avait le droit
simplement debout fait ensemble ça on
pouvait pas interdire alors les tipis
décide de faire des banquets faire ils
se réunissent autour d'une table et
bouffe du poulet américain et banquets
et ils disent c'est une rente le pouvoir
et tout ça tout le monde s'en fout
franchement c'est pas pas ça qui va
ébranler le régime donc va très bien et
puis en début février c'est terminé ils
ont filé leur banquet et à ce moment là
le pouvoir tellement sûr de lui même
temps que c'est ces connards qu'est-ce
que deux pour qu'ils prennent match on
est puissant il décide
d'interdire le dernier banquet qui était
qui et aux champs elysées et ça a été la
goutte d'eau c'était le truc de trop
tout a causé 20 pourquoi canon ah non
quand même ça même même un banquet entre
nous même ça on peut pas un homme là
c'est trop et et voilà il ya une
révolution il ya eu des barricades et la
monarchie été renversées et la
république a été proclamée alors je dis
pas qu'on en est là mais je crois que
c'est très intéressant parce que toute
l'histoire et je pense que au delà de ce
que c'est c'est pas c'est pas scandale
total le cpe c'est pas c'est pas
l'esclave egis et pas l'horreur mais
venant après c'est la régression de trop
et les jeunes et tout le monde dans une
société impossible que personne accepte
aussi demandé à temps demander s'il ya
une chose que je trouve incroyable je
lis des temps les dans les articles
j'entends des commentateurs d'ailleurs
c'est toujours le même art et les mêmes
mots les mêmes phrases on croirait les
communistes il ya 50 ans une mécanique
ça sort d'une machine avec regarder les
gens qui manifestent sont des
conservateurs y sont attachés à leur
statut quo alors conservatrice mais
c'est tout il écrit tous pareils les
mêmes mots très bien s'est montré à quel
point les décideurs sont coupés de la
société parce que c'est pas que les gens
ne veulent pas bouger c'est pas qu'ils
veulent pas le statu quo mais attendez
il voit il voit il voit quoi il voit par
exemple que pendant ce temps la roue des
grands patrons
ce vote des des augmentations de salaire
de 80 %
ils voient que pour gagner ce que
certains gagnent il faut un ouvrier
avoir travaillé depuis clovis depuis
clovis
ils regardent ils voient qu'un type jeux
de la nes qincho la description de la
société par jean brousse vainqueur mais
c'est vrai nom mais regarder les choses
en face le patron d'air france sauf
montant 3 ans 2 83%
quand les grandes sociétés les 40 pour
plus grandes sociétés de france
reconnaît sans façon constante
d'annoncer à des profits de 83 milliards
d'euros moi je suis patron ce formidable
et profite pas qu'aux autres
les gens sont pas quand mais qu'est ce
qu'ils apprennent que ça va pas la
croissance que ça va pas la recherche
que ça va pas à l'emploi ça va au dans
la poche des actionnaires des fonds de
pension et cetera et cetera des îles ce
vote des des retraites chapeaux mais de
maharaja bien
disons qu'on vient d'apprendre via un
type tout condom vient d'apprendre les
23 milliards il a une richesse de 23
milliards en france bernard arnault je
suis très content pour lui ça représente
un million d'années de travail
non mes amis nous reçoit alors qu'est ce
que je veux mais non mais que les
sacrifices pour tout le monde je sais
que ça vous j'aime c'est sûr je sais que
les retrouver partager
mais pourquoi partager mais c'est pas
que les sacrés que tout on ne peut pas
toi ça ne fait pas la fois dire vous
fait des sacrifices vous là la précarité
et c'est assez légitime et en même temps
les gens voient qu'en haut on veut pas
partie on reste en place
on s'accroche à son fauteuil au souk
menthe c'est pas possible
mais regarder les choses en face ce
n'est pas aussi ses vols ben oui mais
enfin c'est quand même un discours
simplificateur et populistes contre quoi
je vous lis je veux pas dire je veux pas
dire démagogiquement fait aujourd'hui on
en est quand même pas loin dijon d'en
distinguer on distingue gens répondent à
mes draps tic c'est pas mal en même
temps quand même temps tu dis que tu es
ghazi pour bernard arnault qui gagnent
de l'argent
moi je dis non et non seulement bernard
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas content ce ne
sont pas les salariés de bernard arnault
qui battent le pavé actuellement les
salariés de bernard arnault il se
félicite que bernard arnault exista doit
pas innover patron de tension ça
n'existe plus à ce niveau là on n'est
pas un mauvais patrons vont s'en mettre
plein les poches après tout ça toujours
été ainsi dans la vie non pas depuis la
monarchie de juillet mais depuis la
préhistoire
ça a toujours été ça tu cites mais pour
monter encore plus loin en matière
historique et 4 en suisse à la police
voilà d'arnaud produit du travail
il produit des emplois de toute façon
jean françois on nous le savons très
bien nous sommes dans un système qui est
un système incontournables comme on dit
aujourd'hui qui est un système
capitaliste est un système libéral
capitaliste auquel nous avons intérêt à
nous adapter et c'est vrai que le
problème français il répond mais pas
celui des inégalités
il est celui du retard pris par la
france dans l'adhésion à ce système tu
répondras a marre marre de votre peau
oui les sacrifices huille-eraud tu peux
pas dire aux gens
oui à des sacrifices il faut faire des
sacrifices louis et cetera oui il faut
serrer la ceinture si tu as l'impression
qu'il ya des gens qui non seulement n'en
font pas mais ces mêmes l'averse c'est
pas possible
franchement sans compter je veux ajouter
l'absence compter que c'est une société
où il n'y a que le fric l'argent le
profit le pouvoir la puissance gagner le
plus vite possible
qu'est-ce que ça produit ça produit des
youssouf fofana
parce que voilà déjanté vol du pognon du
pognon tout de suite tout s'est tu veux
de photos
moi j'ai vu l'autre jour qu'il y avait
la manifestation comme c'était place de
la république et qu'on a notre journal
et place d'arrivée j'ai vu les jeunes
casseurs là les bons et j'ai essayé
d'écouter ce qu'ils disaient c'était
formidable
il disait que vous parlait pas il y
avait des bandes alors d'abord d'abord
c'était d'abord c'était débile il paraît
avec 4 phrase débile
oui leur obsession c'est le pognon
l'avènement la loi de l'agencé réduit de
ce système que tu défends non mais si je
vais chez lui c'est également
l'obsession d'arnaud c'est l'obsession
de tout être humain
non c'est pourquoi j'ai dit que le
discours simplificateurs astrid ce cpe
je pense qu'effectivement le cpe c'est
une goutte qui fait déborder le vase
et c'est une vraie crise et que ce soit
sociale que ce soit économique on est en
train d'étouffer la classe moyenne en
france c'est qu'il faut marcher sur ses
serres qui font maintenant rage ici
c'est un constat que je fais en me
disant en regardant comme tout le monde
mais tout ça reflète un vrai mal être et
il faut faire quelque chose il faut que
voilà il faut arrêter d'être immobile
dans sa tronche et il faut écouter les
choses pourquoi pas les essayer le cpe
où j'en sais rien mais on est viré
n'importe quoi enfin tout le monde est
viré plus ou moins là s'il ya des gens à
certains niveaux qui sont
malheureusement je ne dirai rien qui le
soir été commises les présidents des
mêmes ddd chez des gens qui à 80 noms
sont encore sénateur patrons de presse
patron a décrit jean voyez ce que je
veux dire
à force de tenir ce discours là tu
entretiens cette île légion qui est une
illusion coupable j'allais dire criminel
qui fait croire jantes el baile vaut un
tel et que et elle mérite le sort qui
est réservé à la cave aux autres je
crois que le propre père aime les gens
mais c'est ça que tu fais croire
bonjour le abandonne commencer par ceux
ci c'est derrière bram des jeunes c'est
parce que ce sont les jeunes qui sont à
cause de gens dit c'est ça qui est grave
dans ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
que ce soient les lycéens et les
collégiens et les collégiens s'étaient
dit que c'est criminel de la part de la
classe politique française d'avoir
pendant si longtemps entretenu et pas
seulement les politiques d'ailleurs
d'avoir si longtemps entretenu les
jeunes dans dans l'illusion dans
l'illusion que la réussite de leur
ambition est un droit définitivement
acquis monsieur que je dis ici je suis
sûre premier
vision de gc je le dis dans le segment
où elle attend c'est évidemment courrier
d'un grand père grand père parler comme
ça des jeunes déjà peut-être enfin par
une culture
ces criminels ces criminels d'encourager
les jeunes dans des filières dont on
sait parfaitement qu'elle n'aboutisse
pas y a pas de débouchés à ses filières
ces criminels d'encourager les jeunes à
acquérir des diplômes quand même temps
on est en train d'année en année de
dévaloriser ça c'est vrai je crois qu'on
est à la source du problème
ça y est la saison des regrets bon ben
vous êtes d'accord
non car son discours mais non on n'est
pas d'accord
donnez-vous gage de tourner au moins
qu'on puisse avoir des passerelles je le
connais je le connais assez je connais
assez à la seule placé pour savoir que
lui même je donne est il du jour là il
croque il est dans le vrai il est
victime du sud du discours dans lequel
il vit depuis 50 ans maintenant et dont
il est complice c'est ça le problème
c'est à dire y répète me rabâche
imputable non il rabâche éternellement
son discours populiste son discours
conservateur et son discours égalitaire
le rêve égalitariste civic r datait vous
voyez quand même la preuve de ce que je
disais quand même pas parce que vous
avez quand même un discours qui sort
automatique vous appuyer sur un bouton
comme les communistes il ya 30 ans
peuvent et ça sort avec les murs et la
[ __ ] j'en ai même mérité mais ils sont
en arrière je vais vous dire une chose
je penche personnellement évidemment
qu'il faut totalement sortir du statu
quo qu'il faut faire des réformes et à
chaque fois qu'on a proposé des réformes
des vrais des vrais parce que tu si tu
dis on remet en cause le smic c'est pas
une réforme c'est un sacrifice n'est pas
une réforme mais quand à chaque fois non
tous les domaines la démocratie la
fiscalité le lh l'organisation mène à
chaque fois qu'on fait des proposer des
vraies formes les mêmes exactement les
mêmes qui ont le mot réforme à la bouche
tout le temps les refusent
et il est refusé de qui s'agit des refus
n'est pas cela qui tissent sans arrêt
réforme réforme ne sont pas les nombreux
jusque là où tu fais tu te laisses tu ne
fais que des procès il fait le projet
ono petit tu fais le prochain crois tu
fais le bruit aux amateurs mais j'aime à
faire c'est au patron je dis que j'ai
qu'est-ce qu'il faut alors écoute moi
deux secondes c'est vrai je dis que si
on veut dans ce pays en effet que les
gens acceptent y compris des sacrifices
quand ils sont des essais 1
il faut qu'ils aient l'impression qu'ils
sont répartis justement répartis qu'on
ne demande pas toujours les sacrifices à
certains y compris des sacrifices qu'il
faut faire et que les autres non
seulement leur demande pas mais que
pendant ce temps là il ne cesse
d'augmenter leurs privilèges fin tu peux
pas être en désaccord avec ça même si tu
joues ton rôle voilà
jacques jambon c'est quoi cette affaire
de mais c'est que je vais pas interné
parce que le duo est tellement pas fait
maintenant j'ai engagées c'est à dire la
messe mois puisque c'est un homme de bon
sens en fait il l'est souvent été dans
la charlotte gens pensaient quoi il faut
appeler le 110 que c'est hyper important
car de la blu à vendre voilà
j'aimerais bien y aller dans pas trop
longtemps ce que j'ai pas pris mon
médicament blazy alors à lavasina roch
voisine
oui
bon alors c'est quoi la solution alors
philippe bas on va le savent pour la
france en laissant parler au delà du cpc
à laquelle je répète ce que j'ai dit
d'entrée de jeu je crois qu'un jour il
faudra qu'un élément catalyseur au
système sans chimie 1 interviennent qui
fait alors ça peut être artificiel il
peut être créée de toutes pièces par un
nouveau président par une nouvelle
majorité par un gouvernement une vos
valeurs de gauche ou de droite peu
importe ce n'est pas le problème
il faudra que toutes ces structures
vermoulu soit anéantie pour que dans un
consensus dans l'autre cas dans une un
consensus majoritaire si je puis dire d
une structure nouvelle se substitue aux
structures anciennes notamment en
matière d'emploi puisque aujourd'hui
c'est dans l'emploi ce qui renvoie les
problèmes économiques aux problèmes
économiques générales je dis que ça
devra arriver ça arrivera nous sommes
dans une situation extrêmement
dramatique extrêmement je suis dit c'est
ça va péter jeu ça va péter
je crois que villepin a voulu être selon
une conception un peu bonapartiste
gouvernement des hommes ou
donquichottesque enfin ce qu'on voudra
ça relève de pathologies diverses et des
histoires d'hiver il a voulu précipiter
le mouvement disait vous c'est toujours
des procès certains égards resega
on peut le comprendre y'a même
d'ailleurs les sondages le disent c'est
10 à face aux acariens de la courage
mais malheureusement il n'est pas
politique il a mal choisi son moment il
n'a pas d'assise populaire le contexte
et la veille a pas eu de préparation il
a même pas une véritable assise
parlementaire il est pas l'homme de la
situation et ses fichiers mal pris alors
concernant le 12 le dossier lui-même
alors on me dit qu est ce qui surpasse à
va déboucher
je ne sais pas les syndicats eux dont on
comprend très bien la tactique
son trait emmerder dans cette affaire
ils ne peuvent pas si des d'un autre
côté ils ont posé un préalable
pensant ça a été une épreuve de force on
sent que l'autre allait céder l'autre
n'a pas cédé ils sont très embêtés
pourquoi ils sont embêtés
d'abord parce qu'ils avalent alternative
il n'y a pas une alternative politique
jouable c'est vrai on le sait je ne dis
pas de manière polémique mais la gauche
c'est en miettes en tout cas je rigole
passe quelque part et je crois que ça
ensuite leur cohésion elle et
d'opportunités elle n'est quand même pas
structuré depuis très longtemps leur art
troisièmement et 6 cas plus graves enfin
s'il ya un troisième acteur dans cette
affaire est très inattendu qui sont je
le répète les lycéens les collégiens les
jeunes qui forment une population
incontrôlable je dis pas qu'elle est
manipulée elle est un peu elle l'a été
en tout cas mais ils sont jeunes il ya
beaucoup d' irrationnelles
mais quoi alors il va du rejet tient un
discours réactionnaire 120 lui-même
apple a sûrement eu dans sa vie les
problèmes avec ses enfants
il sait bien ce que c'est qu'une crise
d'autorité sur la jeunesse mais le
discours est actionnaire est à dix tours
de bon sens encore une fois les jeunes
le discours anarchistes des pseudos
révolutionnaires de jean françois
calletta vision rétrograde monsieur
maison tout à l'heure je comprends pas
tout à l'heure ils étaient pour la
réforme la révolution il traitait tout
le monde de conservateurs de rétrograde
tout à coup il a complètement oublié qui
disait ça il ya 10 minutes
et maintenant je suis réactionnaire il
est parfait mais au final vous écris
mais comment vous travaillez en fait
sérieusement c'est ce que tu souhaites
que ça pète comme jacques parce que
j'ose il faut que ça fait que je suis
préparée que je souhaite que je souhaite
pas ça mettra ça commence à péter et sa
dépendance à des porcs ça dépend pour
déboucher sur quoi ça dépend comment sur
le plan politique
villepin aurait pu tenir si sarkozy ne
lui retirait pas de systématiquement tu
as le tapis sous les pieds parce que tu
as oublié cet aspect c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle il va sans doute
échoué c'est qu'il a une grande partie
de sa propre majorité et sarkozy qui
veut qu'il est chaud qu'il fait tout
pour qu'il y ait quand même bon et cela
dit aux journalistes
ah oui c'est vrai ça quand même on
souhaite à tous peut duper vrai méchant
mais c'est sarkozy mais nancy sarkozy
avait été c'est réellement solidaire non
c'est non mais non c'est un élément
c'est un élément un film ça c'est pas
vrai il n'a pas compté dans le rapport
de force il a d'ailleurs joué à peu près
le jeu le prendre le problème n'est que
le premier pas la jouer le jeu de façon
formidable ça je reconnais non mais je
reconnais il est né d'une solidarité
splendide mais qu'est ce que tu veux je
reconnais vert je suis encore une fois
le problème n'est pas là il y a deux
dispositions dans le projet cpe qui sont
il est vrai inacceptable dans des coins
cetin a claqué la championne nationale
voilà c'est tout le problème rappelons
que vous trouvez et à qui ça peut être
tout et son contraire
il ya eu une loi une loi la loi fillon
voté le 4 mai je crois qu'il qui oblige
le gouvernement qui qui qui rend le
gouvernement obligé plus exactement le
gouvernement oblige à consulter les
partenaires sociaux dès l'instant où il
s'attaque à une réforme dourdan dans le
social c'était calme mais c'est quand
même incroyable de penser pour ça qu'on
peut penser à une provocation de la part
de villepinte et pourquoi pas mais
qu'elle soit intelligente qui ne filent
villepin n'a pas observé cette loi qui
est une loi minimale que tu m'aimes une
loi que théorique walhalla aliments
bonne conclusion c'est quoi cette finale
vient pas tant matériel professionnel
parce que ma conclusion c'est pour elle
pas question importante à laquelle je
n'ai pas de réponse bien évidemment et
personne fait ce qu'il va se passer
jeudi que personne n'a intérêt à ce que
dans la situation actuelle à ce que ça
pète ni les syndicats ni le gouvernement
ça va péter vous vu non j'ai dit ils
sont quand même comme un thread jeudi
pour que sa tête eut et enfin thierry
vous êtes d'accord
je le sais il faudra que certains la
france ne peut pas ne pourra pas
continuer longtemps à vivre sur le train
sur lequel elle y les prendre il faut il
faut en finir ce que vous êtes en
déclinant déclinologues est-ce que vous
pensez que l'abondance je suis pas du
tout a décliné l'offre chômage et si je
tenais
je suis très pessimiste à court terme
assez pessimiste à court terme mais je
suis je ne suis pas pessimiste à moyen
et à long terme la france a les
ressources nécessaires pour s'attirer je
dis simplement qu'il ya quelques
réformes mais de base de principes afer
se modifier les comportements du pote de
des français par rapport à l'argent par
rapport à l'égalité par rapport à
l'activité par rapport au travail
arrêtez de protéger les emplois mais
protéger les salariés
alors que depuis dacquois alors que
depuis depuis un demi-siècle en fait
j'adore c'est parfait je ne suis pas
présentée ce soir mon programme des
conclusions jour là pas de questions sur
le liquide
moi je suis très frappé personnellement
d'une qualité à la base mais vous
n'imaginez pas il y a aujourd'hui un
peuple autour des dd 18 ans et même la
manifestation le prouve même ces
manifestations le pot il y a une énergie
une créativité dans la jeunesse une
volonté de s'en sortir d'imaginer des
choses nouvelles de secouer mais c'est
je n'ai jamais vu ça le moindre débat
vous avez un monde fou qui disent que
qui interroge qui intervient qui pose
des questions on peut plus leur enfer on
peut plus le raconter de blague je n'ai
jamais eu mais c'est vrai qu'au sommet
alors c'est terrible général et à la
couche du sommet c'était pouvant table
c'est pour ça que je disais je les ai
dit que vous avez complètement changé ça
c'est évident si et quand il faut se
mettre autour d'une table et dire vous
parlez privilèges alors tous les
privilèges sur la table
vous parlez sacrifices alors tous les
sacrifices nécessaires sur la table tout
le monde
oui la nuit du 4 août c'est ça oui c'est
une solution
prenons un simple exemple finir et là
les quatre autres mais sinon la nuit du
4 août c'est ça c'est puisqu'on ne parle
que de ça de privilèges et bien les met
sur la table sont logiques et romain
allaire tu connais mais sanaa avec
l'année du concours de rien a foutu
réduisent alors c'est moi je crois seul
exemple c'était le 6 par exemple ou
décidé de réduire d'une façon très
importante les charges par exemple 35 %
de réduction des charges ciblées sur les
pme ou de l'artisanat pour quatre
salaires si vous en créez un cinquième
je prends simplement cet exemple mais ça
crée beaucoup plus d'emplois que ça fait
beaucoup plus de bien beau père ait eu
beaucoup de mesures concrètes qu'on peut
faire pour aller dans ce sens d'où le
nom du spectacle
touré zokora c'est son rôle à lui c'est
tout et son contraire est elle qui a
écrit son choc qui a écrit que tout
change parce que rien n'échappe aux gens
france la caravane jacques ils sont bons
mais ils les vendent bien le spectacle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu